CBS News senior national security
contributor and former acting CIA
director Michael Morell is with us Mike
you worked at the CIA for more tea more
than 30 years was this call unusual so I
haven't never seen a presidential call
before where the president has asked a
foreign leader to help him politically
that is unprecedented in my experience
so what do you make a Nancy made a
reference just now to the fact that the
part of the whistleblower complaint
seems to be that it was the way this
information was handled what do you what
do you make of that what do you think
could have happened in the interim there
so I think there's some pieces that are
still missing here if we had the whole
story out publicly then why would the
whistleblower still want to go talk to
Congress yeah so the whistleblower still
knows something that we all don't know
and we have yet to learn that and I
think that's this handling issue
referring to the whistleblower but as
the reporting goes the whistleblower got
the information secondhand meaning from
somebody in the White House and how
unusual is it for that channel of
communication to happen for White House
aides who have heard the call firsthand
to then go to the intelligence community
and say something so it would be very
unusual for anybody in the White House
to talk to people in the intelligence
community or at State Department or a
Defense Department about the specifics
of a presidential phone call but what's
possible here is that the whistleblower
might have been somebody who was on
rotation from the intelligence community
to the NSC staff and was actually
working there when this happened a lot
of CIA people work there a lot of DoD
people work there a lot of State
Department work there so maybe somebody
in the call came back to the office in
the NSC and said here's what happened in
the call and the whistleblower listened
to that that's a possibility well you've
seen it Mike so I'm curious about your
take because the we talked about this
earlier with Paula the Democrats say
it's damning the Republicans say nothing
really to see here that I think that's
why people are frustrated
why can't could both be true nobody on
the other side ever says you know guys
they got a point on that so will you
read it obviously the president asked
for a poll
investigation right that's inappropriate
everybody agrees on that does it mit
does it matter might quickly does it
matter that the president of Ukraine
says he didn't feel pressure no I think
it's the intent of the president right
and it also seems to me when I read it
that the president was linking defense
assistance to the request right and the
reason I say that is both the timing of
the President's request which came right
after the Ukrainian president saying hey
let's talk about defense assistance and
then it's one particular word that the
president used right when the when the
Ukrainian president raised defense
assistant the president said I would
like you to do us a favor though that
word though right implies a linkage yes
so and I think that's probably the way
it was read and that's the way every
other leader in the world is gonna read
it a relationship now between the
president and the intelligence community
you think what does this do for that so
it hasn't been healthy all along right
in part because I believe the president
thinks that the intelligence community
is somehow political and has somehow
after him this is going to reinforce
that right because the I the the DNI
Inspector General did say that this
person wanted Hillary Clinton to win the
election so this is going to reinforce
that view among the president the DNI
Inspector General also said that the
whistleblowers claims were credible how
significant is that threshold for for
the Inspector General so there's big
difference of opinion here between the
DNI IG and the Justice Department about
whether this particular complaint
although credible right he said it was
credible because he talked to other
witnesses but whether it should be
reported to Congress but he thought it
should but the Justice Department and I
think that Justice Department got it
right right in saying the president does
not work for the DNI and there was no
intelligence activity here right this
doesn't fall under the DNI whistleblower
statutes the public what should we be
paying attention to because I think
after a while it's so frustrating you
just hear white noise bla bla bla bla
bla on both sides
you know what matter should we drill
down on and just stick with that so what
matters to me yes is the pudding of US
national security below partisan
politics so if the White House and we
still don't know this for sure but
if the White House shut down that
defense assistance to Ukraine in order
for the president to get the leverage in
order to pressure the Ukrainians on this
political ask that's really bad yeah
all right Michael morale the concerning
II thank you very much we appreciate it